okay well good afternoon everyone my
name is Tony lizards and I'm the
director of strategic initiatives and
the Yale project on climate change at
the School of Forestry and environmental
studies and I'd like to just first of
all start by saying thank you to all of
you for coming to the launch of the
visions of sustainability lecture series
today we are very fortunate to welcome
dr. Paul Raskin as our inaugural speaker
in the series and just to give you a
little bit of background behind this
series this project emerged from a
recent conference convened by the school
and asked in Colorado of leading natural
and social scientists philosophers
religious scholars practitioners and
philanthropists that tried to identify
the shift in underlying values and
worldviews required to support a
transition to sustainability in this
century among its many conclusions the
group recognized that there is currently
a critical need for inspiring yet
practical visions of a sustainable world
and roadmaps to help us get there for
decades Society of course has had to
react to a seemingly endless series of
environmental crises oil spills
pollution toxics deforestation
endangered species and now global
environmental impacts but in responding
to these many threats the environmental
community has often unfortunately become
better at articulating what it is
against climate change deforestation
pollution then articulating what it is
for thus the conference recognized that
environmental research and action has
often not been strategic in pursuit of a
visionary goal and set of ideals to
quote the sociologist Amitai Etzioni
most people are not nor do they seek to
become policy walks or technocrats most
yearn for an overarching picture of what
we are trying to achieve one that
provides a framework for placing
specific ideas assessing past
accomplishments and planning for the
future we seek a vision that inspires
compels and gives meaning to our
endeavors and sacrifices to life itself
it is now clear that the environmental
crisis is global in scale elongated in
time and inner woven with global trends
far beyond the scope of conventional
environmentalism the environment can no
longer be separated from issues like the
current economic crisis capital flows in
globalization advances in science
technology and medicine revolutions in
computing and communications mass
urbanization and migrations and changing
lifestyles and levels of affluence
around the world it's growing clear that
the world must make the transition to a
sustainable and healthy planetary
society yet it is still very unclear to
most of us what this sustainable future
might look like or how to create it in
fact confronted with the many problems
of the world today it's easy to become
cynical or apathetic about the future
yet to quote Henry Ford those who think
they can and those who think they can't
are both right in this context the
lecture series hopes to help catalyze
concrete visions of the edge of the
economies political systems environments
values and lifestyles of the sustainable
world that does in fact lie within our
reach today we're delighted to welcome
dr. Paul Raskin director of the tellus
Institute who is one of the world's
leading sustainability scientists I'd
also like to note that our second
speaker in this series will be Alex
Steffen founder and director of
world-changing org which will be on May
8 over in crew hall his talk promises to
be an inspiring look at innovative
sustainability projects around the world
so now I'd like to take a moment to
thank the Yale office of sustainability
our co-sponsor and the Yale
sustainability food project for their
support of today's lecture and there are
everyday efforts to make sustainability
a reality right here right now in New
Haven and it's now my pleasure to
welcome dr. Marian certo associate
professor of industrial environmental
management at the School of Forestry and
environmental in troduce today's speaker
thank you
thank you delighted to be here and to
welcome Paul I see the problem like this
Tony says Tony what we need is a widely
shared vision of how to get to
sustainability that perhaps
environmentalists have been too much
focused on the negative what's wrong and
now we have Paul Raskin here no one
better qualified to present a vision of
what that future could look like so
we're all very privileged we're a very
privileged just of eating this wonderful
food and to be feeling good already but
let me say something a little bit more
formal about Paul and his work I had the
fan club so I can if you want to get
little bumper stickers and stuff
afterwards first of all I want to
present that Paul Raskin has a very
serious academic background he's a
physicist both undergrad at Berkeley and
PhD in theoretical physics from Columbia
you can see already that he's bicoastal
he's clearly has those academics roots
he was a professor for many years and
although he mostly taught physics he did
share with us at dinner last night
although without the guitar that he did
once teach a course called American
history through folk songs so you can
see that that playful part was was
always there in 1976 he founded the
Telus Institute which was kind of like a
not-for-profit think-tank consulting
firm and still is one that has such
intriguing studies that my colleagues
and I I see we lift sat in the back
we've been just using these studies and
and getting to know the researchers that
you've assembled Paul over many years
because they are always a spark for the
next thing subsequently Paul started the
Stockholm environmental Institute in
1989 and also the global scenario group
finally the great transition initiative
in 2003 the most recent of these
institutions that you've built and I
think you'll hear a lot more about that
today so what I want to indicate is that
what you'll hear Paul talk about is
really based on a lot of very serious
research centered on environmental
policy energy systems fresh water
sustainability climate change and and
and so his group has designed a number
of widely used planning models
especially in the last 10 years or so
he's focused on integrated long-range
scenarios at global regional and
national scales these are words Paul
that have a lot of meeting to the people
in this audience because we think about
these things and we wish we could make
these scenarios and now we have you to
guide us I want to remind the audience
these are not predictions I think there
are now more academic articles on how
predictions fail is there were on the
predictions themselves so the fact that
we have this more integrative form of
scenario building is very important and
let me note that polyserve is a lead
author for the International
governmental Panel on Climate Change the
Millennium ecosystem assessment the
United Nations environmental Union apps
program on global environmental outlook
and the US National Academy of Science
board on sustainable development so one
scenario that I want to present to you
in light of what we're about to hear is
Paul looks back from the future to us is
fasten your seat belt and another
scenario I want to present is unfasten
your seat belt
well Thank You Marion for those generous
words it's a really a pleasure to be
back at Yale now to convey just how
great a pleasure it is I want to begin
by telling you about an incredibly
realistic dream I had the other night in
it and I kid you not I was delivering
this very presentation but not in 2009
the year was twenty eighty four and it
began something like this we gather here
on the centennial of Orwell's nightmare
year of 1984 to examine a stand
celebrate a turbulent century that in
the end brought not dystopia but the
global civilization we call earth land
now you here at the Yale School of
Forestry and environmental studies can
take particular pride in this awakening
it is a fitting tribute to your
visionary turn-of-the-century leader
that our global university system
carries the acronym Gus
so I woke up smiling but I wanted to
hear their the rest of the lecture so
with your indulgence I'd like to return
to the Future to return to earth land
this most fortunate day numa to a
century that's getting off to such a
dubious start now in doing so my aim is
not to predict or offer a blueprint the
geography of the future is a terra
incognita that lies beyond the can of
any scientific prediction or political
philosophy visions of sustainable worlds
are about possibilities not
probabilities still Oscar Wilde once
said a map without utopia on it is not
worth living not worth looking at which
I take to mean that even a crude vision
of the destination can help motivate and
guide the journey indeed and these grave
times a collective failure to imagine
the possible is itself a threat to
sustainability so I hope my story of the
future will encourage you to think about
your own versions as Bob Dylan once put
it I'll let you be in my dream if I can
be in yours
so I stand before you at roughly 140
years of age reasonably well preserved
if I say so myself and you citizens of
Earth land must be your own
grandchildren and great-grandchildren so
off we go
earth land or bust colleagues a century
into the planetary phase of civilization
as our macro historians now refer to the
current era it is timely to consider
where we are and where we have been I
begin with a brief
historical sketch in a sense our
progenitors started down the road to
earth land when they journeyed out of
Africa some fifty thousand years ago on
humanity's long march to the four
corners of the planet over the millennia
ancient trade routes carried products
and ideas over great distances
conquering empires encompassed much of
the then-known world and the great woe
voyages whoa the earliest strands of a
web that would come to embrace the
planet NOW the planetary phase is the
direct offspring of the modern era
modern entities revolutions in science
religion and society liberated vast
latent human potential for knowledge
freedom and progress eventually the
industrial explosion unleashed a
previously unimaginable frenzy of
acquisition and accumulation by any
gauge than the number of people the
scale of production the pace of
innovation the era of exponential growth
had arrived but for all the wealth that
created and ignorant sit defeated
industrial capitalism brought
unprecedented human suffering
encountering hard resistance at the
moving frontier between modernists and
tradition traditionalists mindsets
powerful movements for justice and
environment arose but could temper only
the worst abuses the economic growth
machine just pushed on toward a world
system cashing out nature's bounty along
the way by the turn of the 21st century
the planetary phase had become a
disturbed a discernible historical
phenomenon an integrated global system
was crystallizing with multiple
manifestations economic globalization
threats to the biosphere distance
shrinking technology cultural
interconnectivity and hostility the
explosion of
society networks and so on the planetary
phase was all of these developments and
more it was a systemic change in the
mode of development that was eroding
borders on maps and in minds and in
meshing people and places in one global
system with one shared destiny the world
itself was becoming a stage for crises
for contending forms of consciousness
and for social evolution but in the
early years of this century earth land
had all the characteristics of a failed
state Rampur rampant poverty immense
inequality degraded natural resources
conflict between hostile factions and no
legitimate constitutional authority
spaceship earth was flying into the
future without benefit of flight plan or
destination the mood on board was a
dismal mix of despair destruction and
denial the 3ds of an anxious culture in
those days you didn't need to be a
Cassandra to fear for the future it was
enough to be alert to the ominous
reports that came like an incessant
drumbeat
now conventional 21st century history's
focus on the pivotal years 2018 to 2048
the so-called 30 years that shook the
world that story has three chapters the
Time of Troubles
the the general crisis of 2018 to 2022
the house of Earth from 2022 to 2040
that ended the chaos and brought deep
reforms and international cooperation
and the founding of modern earth land
culminating in the world
constitution of 2048 the global
agreement on integrated activity that we
know as Gaia however to those three
chapters I would add a fourth the decade
prior to the crisis of 2018 in those
critical years a great wave of public
engagement and awareness swept across
the planet this led to the formation of
the nascent global citizens movement
that was to become the indispensable
change agent on the path to earth land
frankly absent this movement the great
transition scenario would have probably
been no more than a minor entry in the
annals of utopian thought or more
importantly world history could have
well veered toward the fortress world
scenario that so many then feared indeed
it very nearly did I refer her to the
new earth order episode in the desperate
2020s the Neos were an international
association of political business and
military elements with the
self-proclaimed mission of preventing
global collapse their idea was to
establish an emergency world authority
that would impose martial law and seize
control of vital resources well in the
event this grandiose cabal was rather
short-lived and farcical and during
their long years of detention the Neos
had Apple time to ponder their
miscalculation for all the while the
global citizens movement was edging
toward its tipping point now the civil
society activism of the 1990s and 2000's
was a glimpse of what was to come
that eruption brought great energy and
diversity to a thousand issues but was
limited by organizational fragmentation
theoretical incoherence and the lack
of a compelling alternative vision
progress painstakingly one here and
there was overwhelmed by systemic
deterioration local success stories did
not add up to a new pathway for global
development the civil society upsurge
both made the global citizens movement
possible and highlighted its necessity
for developments were critical for this
evolutionary coalescence first the
movement cultivated unity through a
politics of trust a commitment to
seeking common ground and building
bridges to tolerating proximate
differences in order to nurture the
ultimate basis for solidarity second it
offered a systemic conceptual framework
for connecting issues as part of a
common project for social and ecological
transformation third its pragmatic
vision provided a coherent legitimate
and rigorous alternative that inspired
hope and confidence and fourth its
strategic sophistication brought
victories and in their wake
new adherence beyond the tipping point
was a bandwagon the global citizens
movement was the tangible political and
cultural expression of this great
transition but it was rooted in a
parallel transition then underway in the
realm of the human heart people were
returning to the most fundamental
questions how shall we live who should
we be what matters gradually the
dominant values of yesteryear
consumerism individualism
anthropocentrism were giving way to a
new triad quality of life human
solidarity and an ecological sensibility
this emerging suite of values was too
become the very foundation of the entire
edifice of contemporary planetary
society today these are expressed in
varying weights and meanings across our
diverse region but are the cynic wanan
nearly everywhere let's consider the
three values in turn that the
enhancement of the quality of life
should be the goal of development is now
so self-evident it must be remembered
that over the eons the problem of
scarcity and survival what Keynes called
the economic problem dominated existence
then with the industrial cornucopia the
historic possibility opened for a
post-scarcity civilization our ethic of
material sufficiency has roots in the
early decades of the transition when the
search began for more meaningful and
satisfying ways of living than the work
and by treadmill had on offer today
people are as ambitious as ever but
fulfilment not wealth is the primary
measure of success and source of
well-being the second value human
solidarity expresses a sense of
connectedness with people in distant
places and the unborn who will live in a
distant time it is a manifestation of
the capacity for reciprocity and empathy
that lies deep in the human psyche the
golden rule that is a thread across the
world's religions as a secular doctrine
it is the basis for the ideals of
democracy tolerance respect equality and
rights
finally with their strong ecological
sensibility people today are mystified
and horrified by the feckless
indifference of earlier generations
where the right to dominate nature was
once held sacrosanct people today hold a
deep reverence for the natural world
finding in it endless wonder and
enjoyment rook
no more our relationship to the earth is
tempered by the humility that comes with
understanding humanity's place in the
web of life and dependence on its bounty
I'd like to turn now to the political
structure of earth land and our slogan
one world many places now throughout
history the ambit of inter personal
affiliation has expanded family clan
tribe village cities nation today
identity and citizenship has reached a
level of the planet
now this possibility had long been
dismissed by mainstream political theory
and that skepticism should not be
surprising looking forward world
historic shifts in popular consciousness
can seem impossibly quixotic looking
back they can come to seem inevitable
for example from the vantage point of
late feudal society with its deeply
entrenched hierarchical relationship
nationalism would have seen a rather
dreamy vision of the future yet in the
course of a mere couple centuries the
pre-modern mosaic fiefdom zin
principalities and Lucchese and tribes
and city-states was transformed into a
world map entirely etched with sovereign
nation-states once established
territorial nations came to be seen as
natural permanent and even hallowed
building blocks of the political order
now globalism may be as deep rooted as
nationalism once was perhaps more so
after all when we traveled to space and
look back we see an integral blue planet
not the imaginary boundaries of
territorial nation-states
now this 21st century zeitgeist of
global cosmopolitanism
was propelled by both idealism and
pragmatism the aspiration for an
authentic world community and the
practical expediency for planetary
cooperation both the pull of Hope and
the push of fear forged the global
citizen in the planetary faith and this
is I think a key point I said an
interdependent world became faced with
common risks the ancient dream of one
world finally became anchored in the
objective historical conditions earth
and humanity were becoming a single
community of fate now of course earth
lands cosmopolitan principles did not
fall from the sky the long struggles for
rights peace development and environment
where our indispensable prerequisites
and inspiration the world Constitution
builds on such milestones as the 1948
Universal Declaration of Human Rights
the 2002 earth charter and especially
the 2015 declaration of interdependence
that was adopted at the first
Intercontinental Congress of the global
citizens movement be there
but our commitment to one world is
balanced by an equal commitment to many
places the fabric of our society is
woven with hundreds of regions of
astonishing variety although an
exhaustive survey is not possible here
a crude taxonomy of basic regional forms
is illuminating most regions can be
coupled into one of three major regional
types which I will call a gorya Eco D
Mia and Arcadia now these whimsical
names rely on Greek roots to evoke the
classical ideal of political community
active citizens shared purpose and just
social relations in Athens the Agora was
both the marketplace and the center of
political life thus Commerce figures
prominently in Agora the neologism eco D
meuk combines the word roots of economy
and democracy
thus economic democracy is a priority in
these regions Arcadia was the bucolic
place of Greek myth thus local community
and simpler lifestyles are particularly
significant here now before describing
these places further I want to
underscore that these are archetypes
actual regions are rarely pure cases and
let's remember some troubled regions are
still mired in the conflicts of the past
and have yet to solidify a clear
identity within earth land now a gorian
regions would be most recognizable to a
visitor from a century ago relative to
other regions they tend to be more
conventional and lifestyles and
institutions their economies are largely
based on shareholder corporations and
investment capital is privately held but
a comprehensive regulatory framework
aligns business behavior with social
goals in order to maintain
highly equitable responsible and
environmental societies the
distinguishing feature of eco Dee Mia is
its fundamental departure from
capitalism its system of economic
democracy banishes the capitalists from
two crucial arenas of economic life
first the conventional model of the firm
based on private owners and hired
workers has been replaced by worker
owned enterprises along with nonprofits
and highly regulated small businesses
second private capital markets have
given way to socialized investment
processes in which publicly controlled
regional and community banks apply
social environment environmental and
financial criteria in recycling social
savings Arcadia features more
self-reliant economies smaller
enterprises and face-to-face democracy
at least in cyberspace these are
relatively time rich and slow-moving
places but at the same time Arcadia
hosts centers of innovation in such
areas as organic agriculture modular
solar technology and human scale
transport devices and as you know
Arcadia is the source of considerable
artistic ferment now some argue that
these three regional types a gorya
Academy and Arcadia our descendants of
the three political isms capitalism
socialism and anarchism although I find
this claim to be rather facile I must
acknowledge its grain of truth after all
a goriias market emphasis does give it a
capitalist orientation some pundit
recently called a gorya sweden supreme
eco d Mia's insistence on the primacy of
social ownership was the essence of
classical socialism
Arcadia's stress on small-scale
endeavors was central to the humanistic
and our
it's tradition but these ideological
associations mask as much as they reveal
a goriias dedication to sustainability
and justice is of a different order than
even the most outstanding social
democracies of the past Eko Dimas
commitment to democracy rights and
environment bears little resemblance to
the autocratic socialist experiments of
the 20th century
our KT is highly sophisticated
participants in world affairs not the
pastural utopias of the old anarchist
dreamers now one of our greatest
challenges has been fashioning a
workable balance between the competing
apparent imperatives of global
responsibility and regional autonomy the
solution was remarkably simple though it
was long invisible because of the
mystifications of the Cold War the era
of the hegemon and the Great Recession
and then the Time of Troubles earth
lands political philosophy rests on the
principle of constrained pluralism let
me explain constrain pluralism includes
three complementary ideas irreducibility
subsidiarity and heterogeneity the
irreducibility principle states that the
adjudication of certain issues is
necessarily and properly retained at the
global level of governance the
subsidiarity principle dictates that the
scope of irreducible global Authority be
sharply limited that is to promote
effectiveness transparency and
participation decision-making should be
guided to the most local level feasible
the heterogeneity principle validates
the rights of regions to pursue diverse
forms of development constrained only by
their obligations to meet global
responsibilities now these principles
are enshrined
in the world Constitution and it would
be difficult to find anyone who finds
them objectionable however their
implementation in practice is a matter
for the political arena what should be
considered irreducibly global is a tug
of war between advocates for a more
tight-knit world state and those for a
more regionally based Commonwealth
nevertheless the consensus is strong on
the core responsibilities of global
governance human rights care for the
biosphere peace and justice world
Commerce and finance space exploration
planetary infrastructure and of course
the aforementioned
global university system now the world
assembly includes both regional
representatives and at-large members
selected by popular vote in worldwide
elections at-large representation gives
voice to one world politics stimulating
for example the formation of world
parties as a counterweight to regional
parochialism strong regional
representation ensures that the many
places are not forgotten this balance
safeguards against tyranny from above or
below and of course the global citizens
movement is still at it
educating monitoring and where necessary
protesting now today the economy is
understood as a as a means to social and
environmental and rather than an end in
itself the forms of business enterprises
are highly varied nonprofits continue to
surge particularly in eco demian arcadia
but also in Agoura business forms
include the worker-owned cooperative of
eco d mia the small private operations
typical of arcadia and the corporations
of a gorya long ago we chartered to
ensure primacy of social purpose not
shareholder profit also a labor in
tensive secondary economy has expanded
alongside the high-tech base this
so-called people's economy produces a
breathtaking array of aesthetic goods
and skilled services now with the
exception of a small group of regional
parties that advocate extreme autarky
the consensus is strong that global
trade is a legitimate feature of earth
lands economy that legitimacy does not
rest however on the discredited
arguments of neoclassical economics that
equate free trade with efficiency and
development rather our trade regime is
designed to help bind a world culture
while taking care not to subvert
regional prerogatives our dispute
resolution system is busy indeed
mediating this boundary now the world
economy has quadrupled since the early
years of this century and with tighter
distributions of income between and
within regions the material well-being
of the average citizen is far higher
everyone has a right to a basic standard
of living provided through a guaranteed
minimum income a full employment policy
or a more traditional welfare system
depending on the regional approach now
it is true that in a place like the
United States average income today is
somewhat lower than back then but the
comparison is misleading in those days
the GDP included enormous waste and
defensive expenditure and average
incomes were elevated by a bygone class
of the super-rich real measures of
well-being and development have never
been higher now along the way earth
lands egalitarian values and muted class
distinctions have helped erode all old
bigotries after generations of struggle
equality for women and minorities is
close at hand
this would not have happened and would
remain vulnerable to stagnation are even
reversible are even reversal without the
continued vigilance of our rights
movements on the environmental front
earthling in earth land inherited the
terrible legacy of a degraded biosphere
and destabilized climate the ecological
emergency of the first half of this
century was nearly catastrophic but it
did spawn the vibrant environmentalism
that was so essential to the vitality of
the global citizens movement and the
birth of earth land as we know it today
we mourn what has been lost but take
comfort in knowing that our damaged
planet is on the plow on the path to
recovery now the story of the
sustainability transition has often told
the turning toward less material
intensive consumption patterns the
creation of closed-loop industrial
ecology and the big push on efficiency
and renewables the ecological
agricultural revolution the greening of
transport systems in addition the great
transition has also been a demographic
transition population is stabilizing at
about 7 billion some 2 billion below
turn-of-the-century projections all the
more remarkable since life expectancy is
now approaching 100 years the decrease
in fertility rates was largely due of
course to the empowerment of women and
the crash program to eliminate poverty
now another important driver of
sustainability was the move toward more
compact settlement patterns like the
popular town within the city that place
home work Commerce and leisure in close
proximity along with advanced virtual
workplaces this new metropolitan vision
has abolished the traffic
commutes and the airport mayhem that
once tortured working men and women
people walk bike and use high-tech
transportation networks that link
communities to local hubs those hubs to
one another and larger cities and people
still drive but more sparingly often for
touring and special errands the
restoration of the biosphere remains a
powerful collective enterprise of the
country of Earth land people monitor
environmental indicators as closely as
they do sports results or weather
forecasts happily we are on track to
reach the goal set back in 2025 of
reducing atmospheric carbon dioxide
concentrations to 350 parts per million
by the end of this century the next
campaign now in the works to return
concentrations to pre-industrial levels
will keep climate change at the
forefront of our concerns for decades to
come
now this extension of life expectancy
and smaller family size has led to
adjustments in family structures while
the traditional nuclear family is still
common in most regions and prevalent in
a gorya alternative living arrangements
have also proliferated such as eco D
Mia's intentional communities often
organized around workplace collectives
and Arcadia's many communal experiments
diversity and living choices is part and
parcel of the age of tolerance and
pluralism it's even the case that some
people are still enthralled by
conspicuous consumption though they tend
to be seen as a rather vulgar and an
unevolved for most the pursuit of money
has given ground to the pursuit of
creative skills relationships
communities and the life of the mind all
made possible by the abundance of a once
scarce community once again sorry once
scarce commodity
time the old cynics who feared the
masses would squander abundant free time
were mistaken the humanists who spoke of
untapped human potential for cultivating
the art of life were on point if there
are limits to our goals and capacities
we are not yet near them well the future
is rushing toward me but I'll briefly
mention three broad tendencies in the
area of religion and spirituality
secularization experimentation and a
reinvention first people increasingly
find meaning and transcendence in the
down-to-earth
marvels of art life and nature second a
profusion of experimental religions
offer unique blends of mythology and
meta meta physics and the comforts of
collective ritual third the major
religions have reinvented themselves as
strong bearers of our core planetary
values the great transition was in part
a battle for the soul of the church
mosque temple in synagogue ultimately
those rooting tolerance and
sustainability in theological tradition
prevail I do want to confess though some
concern about a spiritual restlessness
that seems to be spreading among some of
our young people finding the challenges
of the planetary phase rather old-hat
these children of earth land are
searching for new frontiers many are
drawn to the post mundial movement with
its dream of space colonization and
contact with a still wider community of
life I don't think I'm the only veteran
of the great transition mindful of the
unfinished transformation right here on
the home planet you'll find ourselves in
the unfamiliar and uncomfortable role of
the skeptic
Earthland has accomplished a great deal
but remains a work in progress we are
real people facing real challenges
pockets of poverty remain conflict
flares on occasion greed and intolerance
are still with us and the ecosphere
still suffers from old wounds the only
certainty about the future is surprise
the one constant change still we are
healing and learning and looking ahead
with hope and enthusiasm history is
unfolding in a theater of possibility
that few would trade for this gift we
are indebted to those who rose to the
promise of the planetary phase when the
century was still young living in
yesterday's tomorrow we can confirm what
they could only imagine another world
was possible thank you
well good citizens you may have some
questions well my own journey of
discovery in my own career well I have I
guess I had the good fortune that my
research interests have tracked the
changing times so that the issues that I
was was studying became more extended in
space arched over greater periods of
time and became more integrated in in a
complex systemic framework so one of the
trans ice is an awareness of the
interconnection between these various
issues and the need to address them not
slicing and dicing in a piecemeal
fashion but through a holistic process
of transformation that can be
synergistic otherwise we're not going to
get there other trends for me are being
involved with this wonderful
proliferation of international groups
who are involved in all these issues and
themselves are very responsive to this
idea that you know getting people out of
their separate tents in under the same
umbrella they begin to see that the
challenges that they are facing whether
it be environment issues climate rights
poverty and so on are expressions of the
same phenomena and therefore the
dialogue that happens there can be very
powerful in discovering an awareness of
how to deal with those collectively so
that that's that's what I say it would
be another trend a third I think is
starting to see I think in an increasing
way and perhaps a latent way the
blooming of these values that I discuss
hi I'm Emma and I'm a second-year
masters of environmental management
student at the forestry school and I
wanted to ask it sounds like your
observation of the importance of these
different social movements and groups
harkens back to or refers to what has
been described by hawk and in in his
description of all the other groups that
have emerged on these different topics
but in your speech you talked about the
global citizens movement and do you do
you think that a unification of these
different sort of separate trends is is
required to move forward to the through
the great transition my own feeling is
that faith that the spontaneous actions
of these dispersed groups of which there
are tens of thousands a lot of quiet
heroes that there the faith that that
will aggregate as an agent of change at
the scale of the challenge is just that
it's a matter of faith and that it is
important for us to think about
historically when you have had systemic
change it involved a coming together of
groups who began to identify themselves
in a more systemic way that could
address the underlying roots of the
problem so I know as I said in my
presentation you know and I'll say it
again I think this the civil society
movement is the precondition it's the
necessary condition but it's not the
sufficient condition for the transition
because of this of this fragmentation
there's almost in some cases this almost
philosophical concern
about an integrated narrative of what
could happen and also the lack of being
willing are able to describe what that
other world is in the slogan another
world is possible so I think that to get
from that stage of just this kind of
popcorn going off with tens of thousands
of activists which often leads I'm
afraid to feelings of frustration among
them resignation and often despair and
burnout one needs a more sustained and
holistic process I call it the global
citizens movement when I was your age
the civil rights movement was happening
and it was in the air and then at one
point were very rapidly it became kind
of like a unified zeitgeist that got
such political momentum that it actually
changed history I think we're in that
period before that crystallization so we
need to push on all these fronts but I'm
expecting and actually actively trying
to cultivate a discourse where we can
talk about this global citizens movement
in a way that rejects both the faith in
bottom-up spontaneity reaching the
coherence that's equal to the challenge
but also the the old idea of the
top-down notion of leadership we need to
invent a form of means that's consistent
with the ends of Earthling hi there my
name is Seth also from the forestry
school and my question is and in order
to achieve these these future scenarios
you've described corporations and
capital you know productivity has been
tamed in some way and I'm wondering and
also the way in which politics is
employed has been changed as well and
I'm wondering if you have any sort of
insights and how one might go about
taming the corporation both in terms of
allowing us to be more than just
investors in consume and consumers and
also taming them in the political sphere
so that we can actually activate our
ability to choose on terms that exceed
just investment consumption
no I think my answer would have been
different
six months ago than it is now I think
we've actually been seeing sort of a sea
change in this kind of faith in
unregulated free markets did yes yes
thank you Mike yes yes I can curb my
preface is only to perhaps make my
response more plausible the I mean I
don't I don't think we ought to have
unitary answers to questions like this
and this is sort of like the you know
the strategy behind having multiple
regions and all that there's no question
that the basic charters the basic
corporate charters would have to be
transformed and anything like the world
I'm talking about here so you know the
corporation is itself historically
constituted you know its modern form has
not been around that many centuries so
in that process one would have to
actually change the governance and the
legal requirements of corporate identity
which is what would happen in a place
like a Goryeo so even today you find
gradations if you're in Sweden looking
at the kind of framework that the any
attitudes you the values the attitudes
between the corporate world is slightly
different than the US and one I want has
to imagine here I think a situation
where the you know that the basic
motivations that you know the
corporation is an evolutionary it's in
in ecology it's an evolutionary system
and people in them are fine people but
they have to conform to the logic of
that system you have to change the logic
you can't change the logic without
changing corporate charters you can't
change the corporate charters unless
there's the political space for doing
that you don't have the political space
for doing that unless there's a global
citizens
hi my name is Fran Moore I'm a student
at the forestry school and in your
narrative you kind of described a time
of trouble in other words things are
getting worse before they're getting
better I was wondering do you see that
as I kind of never cry sis of a
necessary condition for this great
transformation and if so how bad the
things have to get before they start
getting better with the three bears not
too much not too little
actually in ninety five I formed this
global scenario group to help try to
think this through and the only way we
could actually get consensus on this
really see change in consciousness and
institution was by putting in our
narrative a systemic crisis I think that
what's happening now is we're moving
towards a place where there is a
tremendous interaction between social
environmental and economic systems in
ways that are very hard to map and the
causalities are reciprocal and heart and
really hard to sort out my own guess is
that we are probably facing some kind of
systemic crisis I don't think what we're
seeing today is the big one I think what
we're seeing today is largely an event
within the economy so when I talk about
the Time of Troubles of 2018 2020 to I
think see it as a system a systemic
event where there could be all sorts of
feedback climate change is happening
social disruption migration feeds back
on the economy in ways you can't even
track and unfortunately that kind of
rippling and cascading effect could be
triggered by any number of events like
an abrupt change in climate that comes
sooner than we hope like a macro
terrorist attack like Peak Oil like a
pandemic
and so on so you know the key point
again is the next 10 years insofar as
there is this emergence of this global
engagement two things happen first of
all it immediately ameliorate the crisis
because people would be involved in
pushing a guy like Obama to do the right
thing
second of all it allows you if there is
a crisis to recover from the crisis so
you don't go towards the Neos towards
the fortress world scenario that that
allows for a creative and progressive
response to it so you know I don't
predict but you know I think the you
know the the way the world by fur case
over the next 10 or 20 years will be
sensitively dependent on what happens in
the coming period I enjoyed my name is
Gloria light I'm the wife of an alumnus
I was very happy to hear about 2084 and
the upside but I couldn't quite quell my
realism and I was wondering you know
what you would do between now and 2025
to deal with such issues as human
aggression destructiveness violence and
and weapons in some magical way we're
never gonna get rid of those things but
at the same time human cultures and
human beings are social we're social
animals and and we have evolved and
changed over time what I'm trying to
argue here is that the very forces that
are leading to the emergency are forging
the basis for transcending it so that
it's not just that we decide to be
different that the idea of
Earthland becomes not only a good idea
it becomes a necessity at this period of
history you know a possibility and a
necessity for survival even so these are
the objective conditions that I think we
will an hour I mean I see this around
the world people are changing and
starting to plug in and become aware of
what's going on it's not a majority but
it's a growing minority so you know I
what I'm trying to paint a picture is
not of utopia as I say real people and
we got problems and crises and and all
these kinds of things you probably even
have a you know earth line probably has
you know an intervention force to
prevent wars between regions so I don't
think we want to be saying that we have
eradicated
you know these basic things however you
know the the ideas of the Enlightenment
the ideas of tolerance and democracy and
so on and so forth have taken a hit over
the last couple hundred years if it is
not the case that this current phase of
history is going to cultivate those
enlarged values and moderate behaviors
then we do get a fortress world so you
know we're still in the game here but
pessimism is its own reward I mean if
we're inactive and we assume that you
know climate disaster is a done deal you
can count on it it's a done deal so we
have to make this kind of a bargain I
think it was Antonio Gramsci that once
said pessimism of the intellect optimism
of the will because the choices that we
make are part of the objective
conditions that will determine whether
or not there is a basis for optimism
I'm rolling Clement and will fashion
Denver a Mentalist I came here to the
School of Forestry 20 years ago as a
visiting fellow to begin discussing
these themes so what I'd suggest that
you and the faculty agreed to do this
five years in a row to find out and many
of these utopian themes which must be
utopian are picked up by the graduate
students and developed so they'll be an
act on them yes my name is John I'm part
of the wider community here I understand
you that you're working to be a
crystallizer of some of these various
pieces of popcorn I'm curious about the
crystallization process if you could
talk about the process of that and also
about if you could discuss any other
crystallized errs for lack of a better
term in this country or in in the wider
planetary world that are also doing this
work well let me give you a physicists
answer to start with that you know all
complex dynamic systems reach critical
thresholds where things happen fast and
unpredictably
are they bifurcate into different
possible trajectories all compatible
with the existing conditions which is
only to say that the possibility of
crystallization or a phase shift is is
really very compatible with any system
that's in a turbulent phase there you
know you can mount considerable evidence
to say that we are in such a pre
crystallization phase that we've kind of
entered this period of turbulence and
uncertainty that some form of global
society will crystallize
you know in the coming decades but that
it's form remains very uncertain and the
very contentious actually I think that
the the analogy I was using to somebody
earlier today was the idea of a of a
saturated liquid so you know how you
pour sugar in your high school beaker
and it fills up and you can't see the
sugar right but it's saturated so it's
becomes very sensitive to any
disturbance so you tap on that on the
beaker and crystallizes a bunch of sugar
okay I think I think there's an analogy
here with cultural crystallization I
think there are a lot of you know people
going to a lot of awareness building a
lot of changing a lot of reflection and
I I am making the assumption I don't
think we're at the saturated point now
we're a mere tip under glass and make a
difference but I see myself doing and my
colleagues doing is we're still pouring
sugar in you know to try to bring people
to that tipping point I do want to
personally experiment with the idea that
I mentioned in the talk of an
Intercontinental Congress there are
parallel groups in Europe you know
actually everywhere there are parallel
groups that have popped up so you could
say bear a family resemblance to each
other
you know trying to sort out this
question of transition the question of
Earthland
which I call her that and we are now
just as we speak
making contact with all those
organizations and seeing if we can get
an initiative of initiatives and maybe
build towards this Intercontinental
Congress to see if we've reached that
saturation point I don't know I've
considered this in experimental science
and I have you know great respect for
the complexity and uncertainty of this
situation so I think we need to do be
think we need to be adaptive I think we
need to have our like a sailor eyes on
the destination but you're tacking in
different ways depending on
to learn and what evolves and what
develops but I think that we're close
close enough to run the experiment and
actually it's rather urgent I would say
right hi Mike Cohen I'm a an energy
auditor locally and you know there's
there's a feeling that our corporate
structures have failed us and indeed
they they have but it appears that
they've also failed the stockholders so
they're not acting the way one would
expect them to act anyway now if we want
to change things there are you know
there's facts and systems and and values
and the environmental movement wants us
to have foresight so that we value
things that will happen in the future
that are becoming apparent now rather
than try and get people to act against
what they perceive as their values can't
we just sort of it use the corporate
structure which is a very useful beast
but just put it in a structure where
number one we correct the imbalance of
the owners versus the managers and
number two we caused them to pay for
their externalities because they're not
capable of working against their
economic interests but if we just you
know have a carbon tax and many things
like that maybe we can get them pulling
in the right direction again without
having to redo the whole world well here
here I I think if we can do that we're
well on the way to the transition you
know there was Karl Polanyi who some of
you may have read had a book called the
great transformation that he wrote in
1944 in the middle of the agony of world
war two and he makes a very interesting
point that up until this great
transformation which is really
industrial capitalism economies were
inside societies
you know that the economy's played the
role of binding relationships and so on
in traditional society and that what's
happened since then is that the society
is inside the economy so more and more
things get market eyes and privatized
and so on
so when we talk about what you're saying
it really is you know more than just the
set of reforms I think it really is it
is a fundamental rethink on the
development model so absolutely in the
short term everyone's are reformist you
know how can we change and fix things in
the long term we better be you know
visionaries and and we need to work both
of those there are time scale tensions
between environmental and economic
concerns I mean for example probably the
best thing that's happened for climate
change I'm afraid is the economic
downturn and yet there's up its
considerable suffering going on among
marginal people in the world how do we
get these pictures in to see well that's
our challenge is that is the fun the way
to tell a story that no matter how you
come into this tent the environment
you're part of that narrative okay so we
need that we need to work on your
program at the same time keep that
vision aligned
hi thank you my name is Jude I'm also a
student at the forestry school so I
think it's very compelling this vision
that due to the forces of hope and fear
that we will take get ourselves to the
point of a great transition but like all
I think living things you know humans
relate to that stimulus of crisis except
that unlike other living things we have
the potential of making that great
transition have a positive or a negative
outcome and so it seems to me that the
only way to ensure that this type of
crisis leads to the global community is
a sea change in underlying values and my
question to you is what kinds of things
can we do to compel people who may not
already share that set type of values to
shift to the ones that would lead to a
global community are they you know
specifically things like education they
just need to understand the problems
more is it that we need to bring them
into our community so that they see the
contentment and quality of life once you
have these values is it stimulating more
empathy taking them out to a wasteland
and opening up the floodgates of that
you know what kinds of things can we do
human predicament 21st century is doing
a lot of our work for us by discrediting
old values and bringing people to an
awareness I think there's three areas
that we need to make immediate progress
in which I call understanding vision and
action okay
understanding we just need to get a
better grasp a better understanding of
this emergent world system so that we
can with with with rigor be able to
communicate this to people and to and to
get people more aware of the fact that
in this kind of condition if you care
about your play
if you care about your family you better
care about your globe so so this
understanding both scientific and a
popular culture is one area vision if
you were alive in the nineteenth century
you would have had a vision you had a
Marxist vision of the alternative and it
was able to galvanize a lot of the
discontent that was around then we don't
have a vision so we don't have a
legitimate and coherent story to tell
about how we can move towards this earth
land and we know how to keep the lights
on so to speak so we need to get
together and enhance this vision and
debate it and pull it together and it
might have many different forms at the
same time it might have underlying
shared contours third areas action I've
said a lot about that you know please
2015 be at that at first that first
meeting of the global citizens movement
but but I do want to say that all right
let me let me see if I can remember
these lines from from Seamus Heaney who
said hope history says do not hope this
side of the grave then once in a
lifetime the longed-for
tidal wave of justice can rise up and
hope and history rhyme well you know in
these kinds of crisis periods the the
old structures that contain
consciousness and institutions start to
weaken in an open space for rapid change
I think this is what Margaret Mead meant
when she talked about you know never
doubt that a small group of committed
citizens can change the world is the
only thing that ever had so I think
that's actually this is a great time to
be alive that you guys have the
opportunity to make your hopes for the
future rhyme with your vision of the
future thank you very much